افادت الاستخبارات البريطانيه بان قوه
روسيه وفاكنر حققت تقدما تكتيكا في
سوليدار ومن المرشح ان تسيطر على معظم
مناطقها ورجحت الاستخبارات البريطانيه ان
تكون السيطره على سوليدار هي الهدف
العملياتي المباشر الرئيس لروسيا كما
توقعت ان تحول روسيا تتويق ضخم من الشمال
عبر السيطره على سوليدار مشيره الى ان ذلك
لن يكون في وقت قريب وقالت الاستخبارات
البريطانيه نقوات الاوكرانيه تحتفظوا
بخطوط دفاعيه مستقره في باخ موت وتتحكم في
طرق الامداد
تدمرنا شبكه مراسلينا من موسكو رانيا
دريدي من كييف تامر الصميدي
عمر الحاج عمر ما الذي يصلكم من معلومات
عن ما يدور في سوليدر
نعم مرحبا الحقيقه البيانات الرسميه
الاوكرانيه والصادره عن قيادات العمليات
هنا تشير دائما الى الجانب الدفاعي فقط
التي تقوم بها القوات الاوكرانيه في مدينه
سوريا
قال فيه ان القوات الروسيه دمرت كل البلد
التحتيه كل مؤسسات البناء التحتيه وكثيره
من احياء مدينه سردانه همم مناجم الملح
فقط هي الابنيه السليمه هي المناطق
السليمه التي بقيت في المدينه وقال ان
الهجوم ليس وليد امس وان القوات الروسيه
ومنذ يوم الجمعه عن كثافه عملياتها في تلك
المنطقه استخدمت المئات من الالات من
مقاتلينر المدربين والمدرسين في قتال
الشوارع الى تلك المنطقه سلاح الجو الروسي
قد سهل بشكل كبير اضافه انه مدفعيه
الثقيله التي كانت تضرب المدينه على مرار
الايام الماضيه التي ساهمت في هذا همم
الوضع وتحول الجيش الاوكراني من من حاله
مستقره الى حاله الدفاع مستمير كانت قد
وصفتها في وقت سابق يوم امس ان ماينر
نائبه وزير الدفاع كذلك الامر شرفاتي
المتحدث باسم قياده المنطقه الشرقيه قوات
الاوكرانيه لا تنكر صعوبه الوضع في
سوريدار الرئيسكي وكذلك كبار المسؤوليه
يتحدثون عن معركه وصفوها بالبطوليه في هذه
المدينه الحقيقه جلال السويدار بالاضافه
الى اهميتها الاقتصاديه هناك اهميه
استراتيجيه كبيره اذا انها مشرفه على تلال
مدينه باخ من تتحكم بطرق اتصال وهذا همم
هو الهدف الاساس من السيطره عليها
بالاضافه الى انها تمكن الجيش الروسي من
الالتفاف من الجهه الشماليه والشماليه
الشرقيه على المواقع الدفاعيه للقوات
الاوكرانيا الجيش
وان كان الجيش الاوكراني دائما يسر انه
بخمس في حاله مستقره وان خطوطه الدفاعيه
صامده ولكن السيطره على سوف تعقد المهمه
كثيرا خاصه ما علمنا ان هذه الارتفاعات
المرتفعات موجوده في سوريا سوف تجعل خطوط
الامداد الاوكرانيه هدفا سهلا للمدفعيه
همم الروسيه التي تستهدفها منذ الان حتى
الان بعجانه في سردار القوات الاوكرانيه
تقول انها تكبد القوات المهاجمه خسائر
كبيره ولكن لا تنكر صعوبه الوضع في
المدينه
في الوقت الذي لا زال تتحدث فيه كيف عن
ثباتها واستقرار دفاعاتها في مخبز
قبل الحديث عن تطورات في الاداره والوضع
الميداني على الارض اود التطرق سريعا الى
تصريحات في غايه الاهميه كانت قد صدرت قبل
قليل سلمى على لسان
نيكلاي باتروسب سكرتير مجلس الامن الروسي
الذي تحدث ايضا سياسيا عن تطورات الاوضاع
وعن الازمه الاوكرانيه واشار الى ان الهدف
الاساسي الرئيسي من انسحاب الولايات
المتحده من افغانستان كان هدفه التحضير
والتركيز على الاعمال القتاليه في
اوكرانيا اشار الى باتروسوفت ايضا الا انه
تم نقل العديد من المعدات العسكريه حينها
بعد الانسحاب من الافغانستان تم نقلها الى
همم
الاراضي الدول الاوروبيه وخاصه الى بولندا
ما سمح همم بعسكره السلطات الاوكرانيه
فضلا عن ذلك الانتحار من افغانستان حسب
تعبيره سمح للولايات المتحده بتخصيص
كميه كبيره من الاموال لدعم همم السلطات
الاوكرانيه في القتال ضد روسيا فضلا عن
ذلك هنا اود التذكير بتصريحات ايضا صدرت
عن باتروجين فيما يتعلق بهذه الازمه يوم
امس اشار الى ان هدف الولايات المتحده على
على المدى البعيد هو اضعاف او تدمير روسيا
وتنظيم تفكيك المنظومه الامنيه في منطقه
الاوراسيه ككل وان الولايات المتحده
التاسعه همم لوضع خطط لتقسيم همم اوكرانيا
بما يهدف لتحقيق طموحاتها همم اما فيما
يتعلق بتطورات الاوضاع على الارض وفقا
لتصريحات السلطات الموالي لروسيا
السودانيس القصف الاوكراني تسبب بمقتل
امراه اليوم الماضي واصابه مدنيين اخرين
بجروح جراء القصف الذي قال خلال الساعات
الماضيه ثلاثه احياء همم سكنيه بنحو 60
قذيفه فيما يتعلق بتطورات الاوضاع وفقا
للمعطيات الاخيره لا تلك التي صدرت عن عن
ممثلي شركه فاجنر التي يشارك مقاتلوها
بشكل رئيسي في العمليات العسكريه على محور
بخوض بشكل عام همم الحديث يدور على ان
القوات الروسيه فضلا عن الاعلان امس عن
السيطره على بلده بخموس كيا المتاخمه
لمدينه سليدار الحديث يدور حاليا عن ان
المعارك تدور في وسط المدينه بالقرب من
المبنى الاداري بالاضافه الى المناطق
الجنوبيه وهناك حديث عن ان القوات المسلحه
الروسيه يتوقع ان تقوم بالسيطره بشكل كامل
على هذه المدينه خلال الايام القليله
الماضيه بما يسمح لها بالتقدم سواء
نحو مدينه باخمت همم وايضا نحو الشمال
الشرقي نحو مدينتي استراليا
توصيف للرئيس الاوكراني حول ما يتعلق
بجبهه الشرق خاصه في سوليدار بان الوضع
صعب ولكنها لازالت صامده
ماذا عن باقي التقييمات لصانع القرار في
كيف في الجبهات الشرقيه
الفعل الرئيس الاوكرانيه يتحدث خلال
الساعات الماضيه عن صعوبه الوضع في الشرق
لكنه ايضا تطرق الى الاوضاع في المقاطعه
الجنوبيه الا سيما في خيرسون التي تتعرض
لقصف متواصل منذ الليله الماضيه وقال بان
القوات الروسيه تقصف بشكل متواصل المناطق
المدنيه والسكانيه في خير سومبي القذائف
الحارقه وهما اشارت اليه الاداره العسكريه
خلال الساعات الماضيه الاداره العسكريه
الاوكرانيه في خيرسون التي قالت صباح
اليوم بان الروس قصف المدينه حتى هذه
اللحظه باكثر من 40 او اكثر من 40 مره
بالمدفعيه همم
لكن اسمح لي جلال اشير ايضا الى ما جاء في
خطاب الرئيس الاوكراني يوم امس عندما بشر
الاوكرانيين بالقول بان الايام المقبله
سوف تشهد اخبارا ساره في الحقيقه الرئيس
الاوكراني كان يتحدث عن مزيد من التسليح
غربي لبلاده على واقع استمرار القتال بين
القوات الاوكرانيه
والروسيه وكان يشير ايضا الى الاجتماع
المرتقب في السابع عشر من الشهر الجاري
لوزراء دفاع الناتو في المانيا وهذا
الاجتماع الذي تعول عليه كيف كثيرا في ما
يتعلق في مزيد من التسليح للقوات
الاوكرانيه يوم امس ايضا كان هنالك اجتماع
للرئيس الاوكراني مع كبار القاده
العسكريين وحكتهم في على ادماج الاسلحه
الجديده والعتاد العسكري الجديد الذي بات
يصل من دول غربيه بالاضافه الى الولايات
المتحده في جبهات القتال وقال بان الايام
المقبله سوف تشهد مزيد من ارسال المساعدات
العسكريه التي من شانها ان تغير في خطوط
القتال وشكل القتال لصالح القوات
الاوكرانيه في الشرق والجنوب وكانت هنالك
ايضا تصريحات لافته ل- وزير الخارجيه
الاوكراني الذي تحدث عن هذه المساعدات
التي وصلت بالفعل وقال بانه همم اذا ما
استمر القتال واستمر تواجد القوات الروسيه
شرقا وجنوبا فان ذلك لا يعني شيء يعني
شيئا واحدا فقط وفقا لوزير الخارجيه هو
مواصله اا ارسال الدول الاوروبيه شركاء
اوكرانيا حلفاء اوكرانيا مزيد من تلك
المساعدات ما يتعلق بالتطورات الميدانيه
تحديدا هنا في كيف كانت هنالك ايضا
تصريحات مهمه لقائد القائد الميداني قائد
العمليات الاوكرانيه في اكياس قال بان
القوات الاوكرانيه ما زالت يعني تكثف من
اجراءاتها الدفاعيه والدفاعاتها ايضا على
الارض في منطقه كيف وعلى الحدود مع
بلاروسيا وقال بان ال- ال- الاجراءات شملت
تحصينات دفاعيه على طول 1000 كيلو متر مع
الحدود بلا روسيه وقال بانه يستعد في هذه
الاثناء همم يعني ااا هجمات بريه من قبل
من الاراضي البيلاروسيه باتجاه المقاطعه
الشماليه القريبه منها والعاصمه كيف لكن
يجب ان تكون العين الاوكرانيه يقظه وحذرا
ايضا
تامر في كيف عمر في كريماتوسكو ورانيا في
موسكو